histoire qui n'est pas isolé georges
duby évidemment remonte au 11e 12e
siècle assez loin georges duby moi il me
semble que les deux personnages
importants dans votre ville qui veulent
un qui s'appelle adalbert outre deux
évêques évêque de landal bairon et puis
gérard évêque de cambrai mériterait
d'avoir dans toutes les villes
françaises une rue ou une école et j'ai
bien l'impression qu'on les a
complètement oublié peut-être pas alan
et accambray mais enfin partout ailleurs
oui mais j'espère qu'on les connaître a
maintenant un abri hier dans ce livre ce
sont des les comparses personnage
principal c'est une idée c'est une image
c'est une représentation de la société
mère dans les gens se situer considère
que le corps qu'il forme à une certaine
forme et effectivement c'est le thème
des trois ordres de la société ceux qui
prient ceux qui combattent et ceux qui
travaillent le clergé et la noblesse et
puis le reste que dont j'ai voulu voir
cette image et voulait la voir naître à
part être formulée pour la première fois
parler les deux langues albert o et
gérard sont les deux hommes qui les
premiers d'après vous dans l'histoire
ont formulé justement d'après ce que
l'on sait n'est ce pas parce que nous
nous autres historiens ne sommes
prisonniers quand même d'une information
sont pas maîtres comme les sociologues
d'aller interroger les gens et nous
trouvons des traces des traces écrites
et les premières traces écrites où l'on
voit apparaître cette image
trifonctionnel de la société elle date
du début du 11e siècle et ce sont deux
phrases dont les deux évêques nous vous
parlez sont les auteurs et bien sûr ces
deux phrases ont retenu depuis longtemps
l'attention des historiens parce que il
s'agit là de la première formulation en
france d'un principe qui va avoir une
importance considérable dans la mémoire
collective puisque ces trois ans votre
sont au fond
le soubassement social de la monarchie
d'anciens réussissait alors vous
employer un mot savant qui ont bien
souvent une autre plume latry
fonctionnalités on entend beaucoup
parler là je dis aux téléspectateurs de
pas se lever pour fermer le poste un mot
pas compliqué du tout il devrait
d'ailleurs rappelle des souvenirs
l'école communale puisque c'est ce qu'on
appelait les trois ordres ce sont les
trois ordres
mais je district fonctionnalités avec
les savants et notamment avec georges
dumézil parce que chacun saison à une
fonction dans la société
je dis tout à l'heure il y en a qui sont
chargés de prier d'autres de faire la
guerre et donc de travailler pour
nourrir les autres il ya une sorte de
mutualité dont les services qu'ils se
rendent
voilà mais à d'albert on échoir ont ils
inventé cette formule guest que
simplement c'est le résultat de leurs
observations
non ça mendy une invention nil résultats
d'une observation
il s'agit en fait de la proclamation
d'une idéologie c'est à dire d'un projet
de ramener la société qui est en train
de se défaire vers l'ordre et vers
l'organisation stable et parfaite projet
de société parfaite projet de société
parfaite
c'est cela et on devrait dire qu'il
s'était inventé le modèle puisque
vraisemblablement c'est une forme très
simple ne soit qu il était dans ce qu'on
appelle les mentalités mais ils s'en
sont servis comme élément majeur d'un
système idéologique qu'ils en sont
battus pour faire triompher mais ils
n'ont pas réussi parce que il y avait
des des idéologies adverse qui pendant
un siècle et demi longtemps porté sur la
leur et c'est simplement à la fin du 12e
siècle un peu avant la grande bataille
de bouvines à laquelle je me suis
souvent intéressé n'est ce pas que la
monarchie française reprend après
certains princes féodaux ce système pour
vraiment s'appuyer dessus et faire
reconnaître son énergie son hégémonie
sur le corps social en jouant évidemment
entre ces trois personnages bien